- More likely to rip their pants on the course like Tom Brady?
- See, I got different wardrobes. I got a fat wardrobe. I got a skinny wardrobe.
So I'm probably gonna have my fat wardrobe.
So my pants will not be bursting.
- Hi, this is Peyton Manning.
- I'm Stephen Curry.
- I'm Charles Barkley.
- And I'm Phil Mickelson, and this—
- [Together:] Is “Matchmaking.”
- Who has been practicing more for this event?
I'm gonna go with Sir Charles.
- That'd be me.
I'm just trying not to embarrass myself, America.
I've been hitting balls five or six hours a day. I played every day.
- It doesn't mean it's helping, but I'm gonna go with my man.
- More likely to bogey a hole?
It's gotta be my playing partner, Peyton Manning.
I'm playing really well right now.
- Right here. That's not a hard question.
- Sorry, Peyton.
- More likely to rip their pants on the course like Tom Brady?
I'm actually gonna go with me. I tend to squat down a little bit, and
Charles just buys bigger pants.
- That’d be Phil Mickelson.
See, I got different wardrobes.
I got a fat wardrobe. I got a skinny wardrobe.
So I'm probably gonna have my fat wardrobe.
So my pants will not be bursting.
- Would I make a better quarterback or Peyton a better point guard?
I gotta give me the nod on being the better quarterback.
- You know, the vertical leap left me just a long time ago.
So I'mma go with Steph at quarterback.
- I feel like my skills would translate really well.
I’m a pretty good passer on the court.
- Use his quick release, right? Get the ball out of his hands.
I don't want him taking a lot of hits back there from J.J. Watt,
but I think he can get it out of his hands.
- Bigger trash-talker on the golf course?
- Oh, Phil Mickelson. Easily.
- Sad to say, but it's true.
- See, I'm not good enough to talk trash.
Phil's a great, great player, and he can talk trash with the best of them.
- Trash-talker? Steph right here.
I don't know if he does it, but if he does any of it,
that's more than what this guy does.
- That's why I picked Peyton.
I saw how he went at Tom and how he went at Tiger and Phil.
- Whose shot’s gonna end up in the sand trap first?
But don't worry, Peyton, I'll rake the bunker for you. It's all good.
- I'm gonna say me. Right there, this guy.
I could easily hit it in the bunker,
but my guy's got serious touch around the greens,
so won't be a problem getting up and down.
- Better acting: Charles in "Space Jam" or me in "Entourage”?
Charles in "Space Jam." I'm an awful actor.
- Clearly, you have watched "Space Jam." Charles Barkley.
- Who would make a better head coach?
- I'll go with Steph.
- I'll probably give it to Peyton.
- I'm the head coach of my son's flag football team right now.
We're 1-3. It's about the extent of my coaching career.
- Wait, Peyton, you said you're 1-3 as a coach?
Nah, I’mma switch my answer.
We can't accept that record. It's gotta be me.
- Better nickname: Lefty or Sir Charles?
Sir Charles.
- Oh, Sir Charles.
What kinda nickname is that?
Just cuz you're left-handed, people call you Lefty.
Sir Charles has got a lot more bazing to it.
- Better signature move? Boy, this is a runaway.
I'm going with Steph again. Steph's shimmy.
- The shimmy is iconic, right?
It's gotta be me.
- Not 100 percent sure what the Manning face is.
- What's worse, Charles’ swing or my dancing?
- You know, they used to say white men can't jump,
but Phil has proved white men can't dance.
- My moves are tight.
- More clutch with the game on the line?
Both of us.
- I'm going with both of us, right?
I want both of us on our team.
- That's the best answer. We both are clutch.
We know how to get it done.
- With a big shot, with a big touchdown drive to lead
or certainly a three-point shot to win it.
So, I want both of us on our team.
- Who's taking down more turkey at Thanksgiving?
My man, Sir Charles.
- Oh, that's definitely Charles Barkley.
I'm on a diet though, America.
I'm coming back strong in 2025.